what's up bro oh hey real quick name two
names three basketball players for the
Charlotte Hornets for the Charlotte
Hornets three Michael Jordan Kobe Bryant
LeBron James you close yep and I'm glad
we're starting off like this yeah
does grandmama ring a bell grandmama
Larry Johnson
hey Dad yeah what college Larry Johnson
Larry Johnson grab my mascara Q's yeah
not implant Syracuse but you're so close
now you and I'll be your now Vegas how
about he's small guy Stockton John
Stockton hmm yeah Muggsy Bogues
yeah Mugsy Bogues nice and the price I
went to the finals if there was a
conspiracy theory would then be a bias
Len Bias okay he passed away but it
would you add Alonzo Mourning awesome
morning about his kid went to University
of yeah you know he again close up
seacoast now opposite coasts Georgia
Tech Georgia Tech that's right Jordan
who is heads down Georgetown standards
of town and Georgetown because I went to
I went to American so that's why I know
this Georgetown yeah
beautiful campus beautiful nerve mascot
the Jesuit priest Oh close Hoyas the
highest you know yet some point though
oh yes I'm on the thing about bass oh
yeah no no I don't miss basketball I
love it man I just I get excited about
it
I bet bro how you been man great buddy
had my checkup
I'll have him a checkup from my doctor
more than anyone I know it's not true at
all I'm in the doctor in forever
G I had shingles volure skin issues yeah
all right but other than that I had a
check-up that I had a check-up in a year
and a half yeah and daddy cholesterol is
back down oh yeah Eddie's cholesterol is
down if I got any stick those old digits
up the rump er no they don't do that
anymore they do it your - I was to do a
blood test for really they don't have to
go check doing this anyone good and so
here's the other thing about that
sometimes I've they'll find if they find
like like a high PSA account or like
whatever I'm trans dating thing they'll
do a biopsy here's a problem with a
biopsy you go impotent a lot of times it
[ __ ] you up a lot of times so getting a
needle in there and taking all that
tissue is not a good idea so they they
don't do that as much you know it's very
common still do it though right
do it but like the kind of newer got the
doctors that are more up on the
literature gonna you put our fingers
there are better ways to do it
never better always do it you think they
focus more on that than like say curing
cancer just because the doctors were
sick upon fingers in it well
cardiovascular and colon colon cancer
and your cardiovascular that's where
that's what the first then 6% of cancers
are the other ones would they say did
you like brain cancer all those terrible
things but they say to you Aarthi um
daddies daddies what's the word super
healthy daddies like that he's like like
the guy goes 52 he goes how'd you talk
to us Wow he's 45 young young yeah 43
he's all about like nutrition and all
that stuff I mean he's really
interesting so you're all good why'd you
do the check but I did but he didn't
test I've never had done like what like
like your ratio of omega-6 to omega-3
fatty acids that have a correlation to
heart disease and they've never done
that yeah fish well he told me that so
your DHA s
and your eh A's are the two ones you you
should have about a thousand milligrams
so 500 on each but a lot of fish oil has
very low th and EH a or whatever so but
I took four krill oil from on it today
thank you very much and I hadn't been
doing that but every scientist I know
who's into this they do take fish oil
fish oil yeah official CBD oil that's
the one thing over you're gonna live you
gonna live you gonna live are you doing
this morning yeah but it was interesting
cuz he goes I thought it there was gonna
be something because now you're really
healthy you thought you're gonna have
something like oh yeah bad well my
cholesterol has been high historically
as it runs in the family no and I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on
I was really high but my also my LDL was
really high and and then it came way
back down could I change my diet yeah I
was careful so he said now you got no
problems I have a four percent chance
like I'm really low on the on
cardiovascular like a risk for
cardiovascular like for a four percent
yeah it's like the lowest you know like
he said basically will see if you have
not exists elbows dandruff in the see
how that affects it yeah blow all the
time you know it could be so funny if
you had a cocaine problem I got a
cocaine causes a cocaine actually so
I've
an actor who had a heart attack he was
just about to be a movie star
just about to be a movie star I worked
all the time just regular [ __ ] load of
cocaine
did a [ __ ] load of cocaine and had a
heart attack at 50 and what code athina
yup and the doctor said oh well that'll
put more plaque in your [ __ ] arteries
that can't be good
yeah I guess that that plaques your
arteries and swells your heart yeah
there's nothing do they come from
cocaine yeah cocaine nothing good comes
from here's and what do you shirts in 30
minutes on cocaine I have thought about
this I believe that um there and I want
to I want to get your take on this
please do we know that nothing good
comes from cocaine right I mean once in
a blue moon shows of your life I
understand some some turbo [ __ ] and with
the shock in the world up an almond and
you're doing blow and maybe maybe a
Pacus Papa's cialis and it cuts through
the cocaine I don't know I'm sure that
there are lots of musicians say hold my
beer and a bowl of a bowl of good blow
and three tens we talk again that's that
pure Colombian that rock and roll that
rock and roll I said I get it there can
be memorable weekend's on that I got for
the most part though if cocaine becomes
something you're doing on a weekly basis
weekly other than the other one you got
a problem
you're a problem yeah have you seen a
documentary dirt now excuse me not a
documentary it's based off the book dirt
about Motley Crue oh right a series
you saw the it's not a real documentary
but it's based off the boat yeah and
there's actors actually a machine gun
Kelly's the drummer in it but um Tommy
Lee he plays Tommy Lee he's pretty good
too nice gives the other guys he ain't
alex is first like big girl whatever
that's besides the fact but it's pretty
awesome
it's good is it actually easy oh no it's
amazing okay that this series or this
movie movie doc will make you wanna do
drugs and [ __ ] tons of girls well [ __ ]
oh the girl all the girls they burned it
Dodd's
oh yeah and they were [ __ ] each
other's girls and they had no idea and
then obviously homeboy gets a real drug
problem and then
he dies one died boy they alien switch
one guy [ __ ] let me guess wait who died
one of them died yeah the uh which one
God died and early remember Nicky Nicky
six now Nikita - he's a black belt in
jujitsu ball he's alive Nikki Sixx is a
straight-up black belt in jujitsu did he
not die no he's the drummer and he's a
great guy
no no the drummer is Tommy Lee right
Nikki Sixx's we usually use the right
guy I hung out I had a good talk with
him really cool guy are they all still
alive pretty sure I didn't get to the
end of the movie know what died bro
nobody broke oh that's former member
yeah it jumped a former member yeah
whatever
one of them [ __ ] died like a big one
I didn't know I didn't left her
so unless you like Tommy Lee was like
when I was drunk he's the guy who was
[ __ ] family and yes and he had the
huge dick on the one that awesome
celebrate remember that's how I know I
forgot it you know Motley Crue's just to
me I can mow Stu I'm too young for it
but this movie also died like
technically he died but then Kenan came
back yeah from an overdose but I thought
one of them die for sure
boy they look like Kaka now well that's
that cocaine and when you run hard at
both ends Tero father's terrible
father's really Oh Mike well yeah rock
star so the way I look at it is I don't
think any good comes from cocaine I
don't think anything good really comes I
love a good glass of wine but drinking
like it like I like when you're drinking
your escape out or no but I'm telling ya
I don't think a God you know the I mean
are you gonna have a beer here and there
nothing wrong am I getting the hammer
I'm talking about what ice do I spend
enough time on the road it's been out of
time with drunk as [ __ ] people I don't
think a goddamn good what not one good
thing comes back yeah but if you like if
you like to get [ __ ] up at happier I
just do it don't be around me and I
don't hey you know I rolled it man you
disagree
yeah oh there's anything good comes out
well but but if you've been working 9:00
to 5:00 Monday through Friday like me
I'm just gonna hang on my boys and
sometimes you'll let it go mother
Theresa
it's an idea drunk sometimes as you know
there's always time to let loose and get
crazy yeah
but the part I mean if you're doing it
Monday Thank You Sunday that's it pick
your spots hon everyone on this goes no
[ __ ] here's a really no [ __ ] here's a
really [ __ ] not controversial one I
don't think when you're coming up and
trying to make a name for yourself as a
young man or a young woman you're trying
to get some [ __ ] done I think weed is
bad until you're like the people I know
that it's cuz that's why Grogan didn't
touch weed until he was 35 yeah by that
time he'd done a lot of [ __ ] yeah but I
think if you're like 19 20 21 2000 let's
say from teens to 30 teens the third I
just think of you're smoking weed every
night or every day your your everyday
young problem but people do yeah so many
people do it every day and it's like I
don't know man every day you got a
problem if you're doing it if you do it
like twice a week or something getting
work done but people don't people some
do I don't people do they do but I but
most people I know if they're if you're
really honest with them they smoke every
day and I just think I don't know I
don't think it's good for you I don't
done you know everybody is different
with weed but I don't know no definitely
I could never do it for my body type I
get high no but there's some people like
rogue and rights high as [ __ ] a lot of
people write high as [ __ ] yeah so anyway
they can write well no because he wrote
incredible stuff not in Oh hold up be on
it say it's the are you dead you said
the I reason rather than success hey man
you went from the doctor now you're oh
you all you trying to be a guru very
cool
no he don't need advice what are you
talking about we I mean little weeds all
right bro I don't know man you push
drugs on this podcast none are proof
that I do what you wanna do man do what
you want to do [ __ ] hey who brought
the liberal in here have you ever done
cocaine [ __ ] of course he has no I'm not
gonna admit it on air yeah oh you have
Wow you don't seem like the type a man
shrug your shoulders don't push the end
don't push the issue we never double aa
know that man what do you mean not your
thing what's that like uppers like
chillers I like weed little XE you don't
even know cuz you never tried if you
ever done Molly done Molly what do you
think it's alright it's cool
it's not all it's cracked up to be you
probably
have good Molly maybe yeah you know Kat
you done any drugs nope I'm get off at
Brian you know you should do is go to
high school and start campaign a
motivational campaign seriously yeah I'd
be cool man I want to start messed up as
the gym coach now I want to wear robes
and beads and I want to have I want to
be a guru that helps people yeah give
people advice and careers on there I
want to help people with their
addictions like especially their sex
yeah if you're if you're a slot come by
I want to help you out Triss Lutter yeah
if you again if you suffering from five
step program I want it starts with
accept that it's okay well the end is
the workshop the end workshop the work
gradually it'll work the piece that's
right
here it is this is the proper way to
work you've made it yeah congrat he's
feeling Mead he made it Congrats there
and come over tonight here's the curtain
small curtain here's the surprise I got
pants on with her tiny curtain is it
tiny curtain on a shower dude how about
last night I was dressed up as a chick
and chin was there we put chin in this
segment and I told chin wearing like
this weird empty warehouse on mic a dude
pretend you work at Gamestop I'm gonna
be that transgendered girl that was
freaking out and so I had chin film it
pretty follows it last night but then
someone this morning do you know who did
it cat so in this morning
post it with the actual audio you
allowed to use the voice now yeah that's
not sure I don't think he's gonna soon
and hilarious triggers for people though
I read off the illogical matter and I
need five percent love it then
five percent you're so you're so
homophobic transphobic oh shut the [ __ ]
up
I've had people damming bike actually
all of a sudden nothing meaty VG's funny
man do you not to walk in high heels
that was a night off and I repeat awful
they had a size 13 that's incredibly
were huge dude they were so big hard to
walk in high heels I do a its general
joke yeah man you're so vulnerable I
can't do anything
did you like a little bit did you feel
like you or a little bit man feel like
you were home
I was hideous and they had there's a
bunch of extras there and there's like
two bro bros there at around like right
here your though you are the the only
the only uglier trans got would be me
cuz i'm so angular with my Adam's apple
oh but remember when you dropped when
you're the mom on the sitcom 3d you were
huh you're idiots i was hideous hideous
yeah yeah terrible he's really
interesting it'd be tough man to be a
good-looking girl yeah especially were
born a man asia tie tie boys time men
ladies wow that's really tricky buddy
yeah can't tell me they just have that
the small features no hair I told you I
made out with yeah there ought to be a
guy yeah beautiful boys you were talkin
and she was small and she has this tight
braids kitchen she was so beautiful
well I still think about her and it's a
guy fine we've been on this I know what
that what episodes 450 yeah you're gay
man I'm not yeah I don't give a [ __ ] not
you tell you I do not care
yeah easy man damn you what do you think
who's gonna pop up chin when you google
all you know [ __ ] yeah I'm you're
looking for a picture alright never mind
yeah now she was much no but get you
daughter images from each other no way
there goes mine see I would know
computer for sure I would know look in
the bottom his are the first one on the
second row
wait that's hasslein because don't know
oooo not that I don't know
yeah look at the third one you're the
third one on the second row that's what
I'm talking that's too bright that's and
that's a dick on that that's a dick
that's incredible
I mean if I was in jail and have to have
it taped um yeah yeah or or if you're in
Playa Vista
yeah sure that I mean it's they'll get
you man those they can like that that's
not gonna get me because I'm gonna go oh
Jesus
why is it that for real it's funny how
as a straight man I see that I see the
ass and I'm like that's good I see the
body and then I see that dick and I it's
kryptonite to me
it's [ __ ] kryptonite I gotta run the
opposite it's only kryptonite for you
during the day but that thing hanging
down is not it's a no-go man it's a
no-go unless I was doing the Apple
bought I have at it this is another
weird thing my first reaction is to run
away my next reaction is to reach up
grab it and go
hog honk and yank it down then jerk him
off you know just want to grab though
you almost don't jerk it nope I want to
grab the balls and the dick I want to
grab it at the base I want to go honk
honk
and Malcolm yep I'm gonna milk time to
milk the cow honk honk
that's a fat dick oh that's a fat
[ __ ] day looks like it's been used
why is it so many color what a pretty
face
well that's a lot of different colors
it's like worse dick let's be honest you
know horse dick just hangs with a lot of
different colors that's interesting it
is interesting hard to stop hard to not
stare at it yeah I guess playboy let's
move on chin you take that out that
looks like it looks like the razor clams
you know the one oh my god that looks
like a razor clam
that's a [ __ ] overgrown razor clam
you see that's a razor tool and razor
clam you're about to a are a cor Oh
razor that's [ __ ] hilarious I'm
talking about bring it up there's like
that's exactly what is June I tore her
this is how
more I don't oh wow that looks laser
clam yep tear that clam is [ __ ]
that's a meaty clam damn I've never seen
one you eat those that's a meat clam
sure those melted butter oh do you dip
that [ __ ] in there I dare you throw yeah
brother yeah let's go man
don't be weird about we're gonna get oh
wow that's an interesting in well done
chin wells [ __ ] you've done great rep
for that's a meaty razor clam got and I
both got the laser clamps what was it
laser razor you call it a meat clam a
medium meaty clam Oh God
old razor clam an overgrown razor clam
do you notice all overgrown and this
word Disney [ __ ] with people small
let's play with my son outside and the
fattest rat I've ever seen Jesus the
fattest rat was running on the court
diabetic rat dude he was so big and his
tail was like this my son goes Oh rat
too chewy because we were watching with
the rat yeah and even I was a guy he's
kind of cute when you think about rats
they're [ __ ] terrible did you do
about it
remember I'm inglorious basterds when
the guy is interviewing and he talks
about the difference between a squirrel
yeah yep that was pretty wild yeah why
don't we why don't we not
yeah har they say well squirrels don't
share the same disease yeah that's
that's true yeah I mean it's pretty easy
to figure out on the for also that tail
the tip well but is he a fuzzy somehow
it's cuter when you have one of those
tails but uh but squirrels don't can
don't carry though you know he's [ __ ]
yeah they don't focus issue through some
reason didn't adapt to the city whereas
rats adapt to the city they they live in
sewers yeah live underground
yeah rats are gnarly the documentary on
Netflix with rats now oh my god there's
more rats and there are humans
oh yeah and that the diseases they can
carry that where they're immune to it
but if it was in connection with us yeah
and they still hear like a yellow flag
you know that [ __ ] weird it's crazy
there's urine carry stuff that can kill
you I got to figure out what to do these
with this rat probably get rid of it and
went into I have this column and he went
in there probably got to get rid of it
right you got a call soon to smoke them
out
yeah that's the temple that's a rat
temple and
yeah what do you do if you have rats let
me have rats but it's like I live on a
area where there's gonna be like rats in
the grass in the field so you can't get
rid of all of them but the ones around
the crib you gotta kill right I think so
what do you do I think do you call an
exterminator and he comes find something
like searches for the rats good luck
with that
you can set traps oh god that's brutal
in its filling inhumane I remember I was
going to play tennis I was in college
and I look down and I see three mice
struggling right on the sidewalk like in
the grass they blood no they work.they
somebody had put down the glue trap oh
and they were doing that I love
quicksand I go to my friend ago I got to
kill these rats I gotta kill these
things
wait there go my syrettes there are mice
I go there dying in the Sun you can't
get him I looked at I can't get them off
this glue and I could my friend goes
what are you gonna do I go I have to
kill them I took a rock and I said I
killed him because I what am I gonna do
I don't wanna them died like that's
suffering that's terrible I didn't want
the and he was like oh my god I go well
what are you gonna do leave them to die
in the Sun and she's gonna put them in
the shade I tried but I tried to free
them and that glue is that glue [ __ ]
him up remember glue yeah I remember
killing them
I'm are taking a [ __ ] rocket it'd be
killing them no it's not did you eat
them I I roasted them but I'm ever
feeling bad about I was like yeah I'll
do something nobody else do or that he's
gonna do it what else you knew leave
them there so they exactly get sudden
death as a driver that's the word that I
have died of starvation there's now a
son kills them like they get him naked
and afraid I couldn't let him die that
way I just could what do you do with a
giant rat to take that looks that's a
shitty way to kill him that's exactly
what it was right there that's a shanise
get stuck it's like quicksand they die I
don't do that they die of starvation
I don't wanna do nothing to die like
that I don't like that [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] you do man
with rats when you have rats get him at
get it you know my unites cults not my
grandfather's to do in his warehouse my
father used to inherit now my
grandfather used to import
olives feta cheese he had an
import-export company down on down in
Tribeca
he owned a building that building now
would be worth 40 million dollars but
he's loaded before he used it as a
warehouse I remember this very well
across from 388 Greenwich and the most
expensive real estate right now in
probably New York City and he kept giant
things of here that rat will be in New
York if you have food anywhere rats
there's more rats than there are people
new you know if you watch a documentary
you know what they used to do what got
rid of rats single-fire no no rats no
rats cat - cats - cats and the two cats
are there and the rats smell the cats
and the rats are like don't come around
here think about it you're a rat there's
a giant tiger waiting for you there are
two tigers god/man right at the don't
shed cats are so [ __ ] good at the
ultimate kill they are the ultimate
killer you can get a hairless cat cats
kill more birds it's such a problem you
will catch a fish Theon killing is like
the highest in the world you know that
what's that for animal their efficiency
of killing is not hurt I've heard yeah
well that's why I'm allergic to them
though bro I don't see that that's my
suit I'm talking like if you had a
normal-sized cat this cat this rat you'd
like okay well they're gonna battle to
the death like it'd be a great match
it'd be a great grappling match to the
death cat I'll fat ass man cats are
badass but you look uh what do they call
the ones like teacups
what's the ones with the with the ears
though they have like you know Tama the
cat's yeah you know the little cats are
you allergic to I'm allergic
but do you can get a shot now listen
thank you they keep rats away well I'm
doing up title think you have a rat
problem Bubba don't worry about it the
Sphinx cat know you saw the route
Disneyland
he's nobody said you know dude no bro we
were watching ratatouille a few days ago
okay my son was like oh cool let's go
hang out this rat it was like right up
in my house it was her outside he was
outside but right next to where were we
hanging out here all right but he ran
into my column like this little
you're alright you gotta watch the rat
documentary that's where they like he
might have a whole colony in there yeah
he might is it this one
no man the [ __ ] normal I'm not looking
for a leopard sorry cat no they're like
just I think Rogan has them they're
[ __ ] version cats Persian no I'm on
Bobcats Lynx Tiger dude they're cute
their ears are like half Catwoman laughs
come on here's a shorter doormat hey I
figure you'd call him Bob I'd I don't
know yeah I wouldn't you know the cat
also if you have a cat outside know that
the pie Oates [ __ ] him up yeah well I'd
rather you get the cat than the yeah
cats I'm allergic to him though my
family saw I had allergies 24/7
throughout the entire season in Colorado
it took him years to figure out learn to
cats
hey mom dad oh hey mom Jesus Christ
that's awesome hey mom and dad do better
though do better yeah my eyes were
itching like um Oh non-stop and I guess
just allergies it's just allergies well
and then finally doctor goes what did
you guys hear that animal my mom goes
like two years ago he's like what am was
in the Catholic that actually he's
allergic to the cat like oh that makes
sense you know my dad's dammit first 17
years or something around Christmastime
my wife would be would be in basically
couldn't breathe oh oh you haven't pine
about it was a Christmas tree took them
that long though well maybe the
Christmas tree is a problem that's not
it's it's not round ears chin I forget
what they're called man no the only one
that doesn't shed is to hear this one
the one that's like a pair of nuts I
think so I think that's it that's cutest
fire maybe that I think they're blackish
fold kitten back hats really cute yeah
cats are not I can't never have cats are
not kind of suck you tame them they're
not domesticated they don't domesticate
well you know cats also the way the
reason why they're way better and way
worse than dogs is let's say cat
cat has had a cat for like ten years
yeah I can take that cat put it in your
house doesn't make cats does not give a
single [ __ ] that's right as long as
there's food there doesn't care that's
never gonna see you again they are not
attached to an owner exactly because you
not send me your DMS of your picture
your [ __ ] cat because guess what that
cat can go to anywhere and they do not
care that's a cute cat where dogs are
different my dogs they're stories of
dogs where the owners whatever the dog
runs away comes back they moved to a
[ __ ] Seattle and the dog walks to
[ __ ] Seattle from Los Angeles I love
I love dogs me too bad the best there's
a lot of work I want one bad another one
bad there's a lot of work when they're
puppies you get a trained one no I've
been there done that black car
he's got spinal meningitis there's all
kinds of issues there's still a lot of
work it's a lot of work it's a lot of
responsibility and they were my son's
older I'll get him his own puppy but now
it's like well I'm gonna have to kiss
mark at the wrong time this [ __ ] if
you're also have feelings so they want
to be run I get home the dogs like [ __ ]
yeah man
chin you don't will none your apartment
you'll have dogs or cats they're allowed
but no I don't cat do you have anything
my boyfriend has a dog well you guys
have a dog sure I didn't want a dog
that's why oh he's cool that what kind
you don't sound too crazy about him he's
on he's a mutt he well he's just stupid
he's one of those dogs rail you can tell
he's just a dog what breed he's a mix
like a terrier he just looks young from
the pan uh no he's my boyfriend's
friends boss had a litter just like one
of his dogs burn it just one it was
really cute originally but now if you
post pictures of it's all yeah brought
about the dog did you post your picture
your feet no no I did it I know exactly
what that's like
we have waiters like
for me talk about a schedule so what is
your schedule blowhole oh they the worst
is how was your day it's like oh also
going to recap what I just did my
favorite is this so for the summer oh my
god excuse me three months from now
here's me well no I don't know I'm doing
two days from I don't know anything
don't talk to me about the summer you
know it's a trigger for me is when
people try to plan a vacation
I'm talking a trigger Oh fun gray you
don't even know I'm so why because I'm
on vacation with my sister my friends
and my friend's wife and my sister with
all my vacations while your application
I'm on vacation and they go
so next yacht party can I go I don't
know what don't you drama hold on I'm
gonna ruin this week I don't know if I'm
gonna be alive I know God talking about
vacation when you're on vacation the
[ __ ] man don't know moment I can't plan
it's a real trigger for me vacations
when someone goes man you know where you
should go I go oh god [ __ ] you man I
don't know what it is yeah
I should talk to someone about that it's
a real eye thing I think that you vacate
and it pisses me I think you would like
going to Europe yeah if you let me work
and then like and then after I'm done
doing shows I'll pop on over it's like
Franco is going to Croatia then to the
Amalfi Coast then to to like Florence to
shoot a movie and live in a castle
that's different
yeah man at night you you have your time
well I'd be down like starting to just
ah be I'm gonna go back to England and
do the tour again maybe I'll stay
another week I don't know after that we
could doing shows I'm like no not only
get England you go to Italy Spain
Barcelona I mean there's some I just
don't want to be gone that long
that's fair well you also have Kate I
don't know why vacation is a trigger for
me as soon as I hear well your life is a
vacation in a way like what you do is
you'd rather be doing this that I mean
last night at midnight was I pretend to
be a transgender woman yeah I was Brian
that's my life
yeah it's a vacation sometimes a
nightmare sometimes a nightmare
sometimes yeah did you see the trailer
for the Joker
I have it ready for Ojeda
it it's uh because they did just release
like a little clip oh I can't wait for
this do our boy Todd Feldman flew to New
York today for the premiere of Game of
Thrones nice take a look at this Arthur
does it help tell you in the speed
he's so good
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
[Music]
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
because it just be yeah yes it's getting
crazier out there yes to get his team
I've seen I wasn't I don't sue she's
good actor he's a great actor correct
just
any more questions wholly about Todd
Phillips God wrote that [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that looks good oh my it's
just what I call high art and Joaquin
Phoenix having spent four days or
whatever was with him in a room and
watching him work and just trying to
stay out of the way Jesus was you got
you look at a guy then you go well I
definitely couldn't do that he's so
talented talented dude it's more the
idea that he's able to hold that
preparation hold that emotional state
hold that character hold his weight down
for three months movie without a break
it's a different kind of endurance those
kind of human being you know what's
crazy to me is there's there's no one
gets more criticism than a superhero
movie that no one gets even close the
amount of criticism if you make a
superior movie because the guys that
watch that who are like balls deep in or
who grew up that and know the stories
and the backgrounds and all that their
show hypercritical anything you do and
they just [ __ ] on it they I'm sure
that's gonna be probably the best comic
book movie ever made I would assume that
or the Dark Knight want to do right and
it's still gonna get [ __ ] for it such a
good kid you cannot make those people
his phenomenal man I told you when I saw
him working I was I was watching him
they just said you were scared I just I
I I've been doing this so long and I
watched him there was a scene that he
was shooting on and I went the first
thing I did I got there and I went I
looked at Todd I go bro he goes I know I
go no that's that that acting job I mean
his ability to it was heartbreaking it
probably got young people to see cuz
they're like oh I can't do that
well no no nobody can Leonardo DiCaprio
said he's the best actor of our
generation you know it but what it takes
I saw what it takes
I also saw who you have to be for that
and that's not for me yes sir yeah be
super discipline well you outside the a
difference gotta have a different
mindset whatever it is that you have I'm
so cool yeah zero the other better
deirdr than the joke the other thing I
think it was fascinating is that
when you see a movie being made and
you're there and you watched how
piecemeal it is and and the step by step
process the laborious process the actual
process of how long it takes every
detail but what it really takes to be an
actor like that there's so it's so not
glamorous and then you see it putting
old sees that though nobody I don't I
don't know if people get glorified
movies now it wouldn't be active if they
saw it and they wouldn't be actors yeah
like that is we all see as we see that
we all get inspired we go see that but
you see that that so that clip was
edited and probably took how many days
how many hours just use act but you how
long is a clip that's 2 minutes and 20
seconds so that was edited and cut
through how long three months of
shooting oh yeah three months yeah but
no it won't be ready for a year it takes
a year after its shot it takes a year
but that same with everything it's like
if when you watch them let's say you
watch Conor McGregor in the main event
you watch LeBron James and Game seven of
them be a fun yes people fall in love
with that yes you know how many [ __ ]
baskets LeBron shot before he made to
that level but just look at this shot
right here that you see the shot the
lighting the best lighting people in
costume people in the world are on that
the best makeup people have hair people
get is me I work with all of them
they're the best in the world they're
the best of what they do just that shot
right there that perfect lighting all
those ratios that's that is well Helen
that they can set up that shots our
takes well that shot takes I would say
30 people experts at there feel the best
and then how many times I mean old a
full day just to get though they it's a
full day and the consideration into the
color for the hair and the and the and
that's where Todd Phillips is so amazing
because Todd Phillips is the one who who
conceptualizes of the whole [ __ ]
thing and he's a beast soup you know
what Todd likes to do besides make
movies
nothing chill and and that's what I
that's what I love about it and so so
when you see the finished product its
glorious that's glorious work but to get
there it's like will that make you so
there's a strike going on right now with
the writers well I shouldn't say snowy
yeah the writers guild the drops right
no it's not a strike but basically
almost like a protest yes over over our
new media and money and stuff like that
yeah yeah
it could get dicey it's been and we're
demanding like a lot of Mar not the big
dogs but well they're demanding that
they fire their agents yeah there's
gonna be interesting it's a real
movement it'll have direct consequences
for me - yup for Israel in that business
right yeah so hopefully they work out a
deal because I'm sure they will yeah
it's the people working they have the
most to loose in that yeah and a lot of
times the people on the who are well
there's a lot of moving pieces I had
someone tell me whose balls deep in it
who's in the thick of it give me the ins
and outs I'm like Jesus that is heavy
what what'd he say about what's gonna
happen he just he did well it sounds
like you know they wanted to fire their
agents because they're saying it's a
conflict of interest because certain
agencies WME say all these they
represent producers but then they also
represent the packaging deals and that
worked and they all started own
production company that's right so then
the writers gonna hold on there's a
conflict of interest there is a conflict
yeah there are a hundred percent I mean
and then they're demanding that the so
the once some of them not all of them
some of the big dogs who have made it
are you know or saying hey fire your
agents and do this when a lot of like
minority writers and female writers like
hold up we just got representation yes
we're getting the biggest roles we've
ever got yes and you wants to fire agent
yeah well you're you're fat and happy at
the top yeah and you're a white or you
know female or male writer and you're
killing it
so of course you say farm cuz you but
you've made your mark we just done yeah
the problem is that they're the the
writers who are talking about they have
a very strong point which is that there
is a conflict of interest and you will
lose you'll get nothing I mean so this
is a fight that probably if the writers
who've been in this business a long time
are having a problem listen to them
listen some of them are though it's some
of them are there but it's it's the ones
who are who don't have to ever work
again who are saying you should fire
your agent and
my Hollywood writers overwhelmingly
approve new code for agents two days ago
I think I ran out of articles here
I died I'm so glad ya do so writers make
the world this has been in the works for
a while lighters make the world go round
yeah so if you don't have rice you're
[ __ ] great storytellers yeah it's
interesting stuff though
yeah the packaging that's what they're
mad about riders vers agents Hollywood
Reporter six hours ago what's that say
chin what exactly our packaging yeah
it's a lot go on it well the packaging
deal is this small donation sexualizes
from start to finish they represent the
producers they represent the writers the
hoods represent the actors and they put
it all together as a package yeah they
do all as the package right yes keep
going so they they literally represent
the movie yeah everybody in the movie
and it's conflict of interest isn't
because it can be yeah it can be but
everybody's also making my as an artist
I get the point
yeah like when the the guy who explained
us to me I went okay I can't get where
they coming from the top because you
have no power you take the job that's
given to you and you get you get what's
called a WTF I asylum I also think you
giving the agents that much like you and
he's giving anybody that much that much
power of your career is not the best way
to get any time they can package and
decide what to put in who to put in
that's what you're saying is just common
sense and you're absolutely right from a
business point of view anybody who has
that much disease it's gonna have a hard
time not taking advantage of you because
it's what happens is you'll take the WGA
minimum but also what about what about
if you know the best person for the job
so if this HD represents this person
putting the package and deal together
and this agency is great writer results
and that writes proof for the job but
because he's not with the I'm boxing
right it's like one fact what the
promoter of this doesn't let this boxer
fight they have the interest and they're
their nut comes from that certain boxer
instead of the one that should probably
be in the fight over here but they don't
want to deal with them yes that's a real
issue well I've been through that a lot
and then what
also they're not interested because they
can't make money off the other me so
like that so interesting to have
somebody get on here and talk about it
but mmm more on reading before yeah
maybe that should be and the answer
should be over coffee scoop of yeah
well let's get Billy corn back and talk
about it yeah I was kidding what else we
got let's get here experience does get a
romantic man chokes gross store cashier
for smash the bag of chips I get it bro
so there's a man who was at a grocery
store he had his items checked out and
the bag boy kept on tossing around his
items not necessarily just his chips but
he put the chips in the same bag as
canned goods is he all there it was a
messy stable dude he says he is I told
you about Jerry now put your bread on
the bottom that's right put your soda on
top of the bread yeah carry on but the
guy says oh he was having a bad day he
snapped on him because he did it in
front of the man's wife so he felt
disrespected by the bag boy he
confronted the bad guy and he ended up
trying to choke him out to which police
came and arrested him but he said it's
just because he was having a bad day
wow dude some type of [ __ ] happened you
have a bad day you'll freak out you know
I fired off an email the other day I was
on a bad day I fired off an email I was
like oh well can't do that even chin
text me back like maybe don't send that
type of email maybe talk to me first
yeah did you see yeah yeah my brother
goes what's wrong with you that just
[ __ ] dealing with this business stuff
and I went I descended the email feel
bad you know so let me read the email
and Jay goes we can't do that you simply
can't do that he is if you work for my
coming you'd be fired did you did you
call him and tell him you're sorry yeah
I did yeah but sometimes we have a bad
day doing something just pops off he
humps in you get a notion and it starts
growing into its own thing yeah been
there many times you know what I never
get mad as like I don't have road rage
and at least be like people cut me off
all the time or not that never bothers
me it's never well variety bothers me
I'm just like you know old Brides been
in therapy right oh yeah how's it going
pretty interesting
oh yeah what'd they tell you that you're
batshit crazy no O'Brien's with intimacy
huh
really yeah you know like well like if
making deep connection you know yeah
making deep connections I couldn't do as
a kid yeah no yeah I'd say bye to my
dogs all that stuff so like when my dog
got cancer
yeah I'm saying I talked my mojo has cut
off assuming my dog got cancer and they
said it was a thing my wife said you
stopped petting your dog her stop doing
that [ __ ] right now
I was already done yeah but it also has
cancer and it's juicy but it but I mean
that's a liability that's when I met
Brian I came out in the dog head one
erin is juicy yeah how's a kite well get
your dog okay your cancer just hopping
yeah so but they told you have trouble
interesting because you will you know
you say I'm never emotional like I don't
show it yeah but also growing up your
pants and show you like they weren't
hugging and kissing you know there
wasn't it wasn't a venue off to boarding
school yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
that so you know I can be the most
loving person dude well I'm longer
friends so you're a good guy but you're
not gonna I'm not I'm not a sentimental
I'm not gonna make intimate connections
like I'm not gonna be like it was it
really interesting like even he said I
was talking to and he said I said I feel
very comfortable around rougher people
fighters criminals comics you know
people that are a little bit rougher a
little bit uh there's a there's a layer
of this yet I've always felt comfortable
around that soldiers you know like III
there's something about those people I
gone to him and and he said that because
there's I'm not trying to make a joke
that well no because because that those
people make me feel safe and because
there's there's an armor around them
there's that there's an other it's a
similar thing that I do
yeah like like it I I were talking about
what is it about boxing why do i what do
I work on it or what why do i why my
show that's like that stuff yeah I
always happen you don't leave that
accomplished because you were like you
weren't that no I
no because I was a good I mean you you
think I mean I prefer to be honest not
to be a dick I was a really good
wrestler I had my victories as a young
man in that sense like I it wasn't that
it's more because I'm still doing it
so it wasn't like oh this kid was never
an athlete never had any wins I was but
you know I got that I got satiated in
that sense as a kid it was never I was I
was kid until I was 18 and even beyond
that so that wasn't so much the issue
it just wasn't it's more what I get from
the building that Armour and also I like
being around that and that's all part of
that's a liability in a way you know
it's it's it's that warrior mentality or
something but you know it's it's not
relevant it's very weird to do think
about it think about it intellectually
I'm literally working on slipping
punches and I try to spar every time I
go in the gym well I like it I love
getting better at something it's really
fun but why that particular sport why
that in the Mac of my mind the idea is I
want to be able to measure distance in
case I got in a situation it makes me
feel safer which of course it's not it's
not true but it does yeah and it's been
very interesting man to talk to somebody
who really breaks this [ __ ] down and I
don't know where it's going I don't know
where it's going but it's switch to help
before though right ever done it before
so at 52 to see the liability because
it's caused liabilities in my life
without detail 100% you know I'm saying
so those liabilities have been a very
interesting thing to explore where is it
coming from and it's [ __ ] it's very
interesting it's all strategic post it
is more about myself
have you been to therapy therapy but not
nothing
yeah no yeah I'd like to I don't know
what I would do it you can do it on your
phone you know that well Michael Phelps
other thing but I'd like to do it you're
like me you know like me
well I just thought nurses you get a guy
who's like older who's been there
forever and he starts talking to you not
I definitely want to do it in person
yeah I don't know when I would do it I
don't know I do it I know so I'm not
here I'm at home I want to be myself I'm
not working
yeah and you know the thing is that you
can be fine without it like you can you
can exit and be fine
but those liability I'm actually just
curious to know I like exploring and
knowing much you talked about your talk
no I haven't gotten I discovered that
I've not discovered that yet but maybe
that's the big lie Paul I would love if
you came in just like dude guys we had a
breakthrough what happened gay gay I'm
gay bro yeah yeah you always talk about
me feeling meaty yeah I do dude yeah you
know a meeting you know I'm in love with
you I contact why the guy actually wants
to see you boner yeah no no I mean I
just think it's interesting to see where
it leads me I think it's help it's
[ __ ] a new man things anything like
that's healthy because it's new in 30
years too late but it's fine how to
present 30 years too late all [ __ ]
aside
yeah and then you wonder like what would
happen if I had somebody like that at 18
right who could have helped me I mean 18
well well yeah because what you do at
trauma is you waste a lot of time in
certain directions
some people get from their dad though
you get my that my dad was might that
like if I had up my dad's been through
some [ __ ] so at 18 at 14 at 21 22 when I
seven proms why having a dad it's a good
dad is so important I go to my dad yeah
yeah my dad my dad is why this is what I
did huh this is probably what you should
say I never went to my dad I never I've
never done that once behind you there's
real close well I wasn't you remember I
wasn't home that's one of Abby's yes sir
from the age of 14 I was gone no no my
dad I would see my father you know what
on Christmas and so the next can't be
your therapist or your guy you know you
can't be here also that wasn't in his
culture you know I wasn't his dad he
grew up
like I remember my friend went to my
wrestling coach and and was talking to
him and I remember thinking that was
weird I was like I have problems I'm not
going it that's what coaches are so
important coach yes so my coach was
amazing but I never once went to him and
talked to do coaches are amazed I've
every coaches gone see ya great coaches
would I go do that I it's not me because
I never I was embarrassed to go talk to
him about something was bothering me you
know I was a long way you were raised I
was right and we were born
well I was raised not it's not my
parents fall I love my parents but
that's the way they were they were
raised so it was it was more you're
raised sometimes where emotions are
considered weakness which then and their
shame I know it's so so crying was not
what you did no go cry well that was my
baby carry on well I was emotional but
see I'm sensitive Yeah right but didn't
you spend your whole life trying not to
be sensitive because that's what a man
is
it's a getting value yeah yeah I mean
you you grow up with these with these
stories that are niblets to you that you
try to know you know so it's pretty
interesting it's really really
interesting actually it's good for you
yeah yeah I'd like to do it I think it's
good for you though it's healthy
I'm actually very into it and I'm you
see him once right yeah and I I go to a
couples therapist - mmm that guy's a
badass that dudes are trying to sue
males it's two males what no I'm not a
woman a woman about a woman's not a bad
idea though you know I don't know I be
interested alone yeah that's better
I like talking to a dude though they're
older men who've been around a long time
one's gay and the others not so they
have interesting perspectives I don't
know if I never seen a woman therapist
it could be good I mean yeah where I
wear lace panties at and that's one of
the prerequisites in that sense with the
gay Ewan all right what do we got
So Scary Spice came out on a talk show
and admitted that she had a sexual
relationship with ginger spice yeah
that's hot and now ginger spice is angry
at her for outing their relationship and
they're about to go on tour together so
hot I mean so bad the Spice Girls are
back they're back mm-hmm dude also a
black street boys are killing it now
[ __ ] the sporty spices are killing it
I spent two he's smoking she had the
eyes I'm gonna say there's still the
story again she had the best body
probably ever seen in person on a human
being
back in the day I don't know about now
but back in the day well hot enough for
Eddie Murphy oh you know what I'm gonna
fire some real bullets here
my live shots into that didn't get her
yeah they have a kid together don't say
I don't say hey you don't say fire real
shots into her [ __ ] I'd live I said
long live shots and that don't say that
give you a good don't say it
alright man yeah what do you mean
alright man alright man I won't do it
again
god damn it that's why she's so hot
Eddie went you know what I'm gonna roll
the dice it okay fine our fee let me see
her have a video or you want pictures I
see pics of her now try not to pee I'm
Piers Morgan fan I like that guy and let
people hate him I like him I like him
dudes don't got it going on you know
who's you know who's you know who's
neaten neither one's uh you know a lot
of work damn she was ridiculous um you
know who's not very PC at all and it's
just like just hold me to moving culture
and stuff like that yeah I listen to
Howard Stern every day you ever listen
to Howard no dude to [ __ ] their blind
date with Robbie no Robins been a
sidekick for 70 years yeah she's at
african-american lady do you just play
songs about her sucking dick and her big
titties and it's hilarious really it's
hilarious
they have songs and she just goes with
it I mean they're just that that PC
culture just Howard is like very cool
she's keep doing this over here I wants
a billion dollars has a cult-like
following that is massive yeah he does
Howard Stern dude do you want it for a
minute yeah a hot minute right yeah
let's be 30 years stay true to himself
just does what he never waivered never
doesn't do Instagram to do any social
media stated Facebook Facebook live one
time because remember Howard his [ __ ]
used to be free then he went dis serious
and they paid more than [ __ ] hundred
Godley off 300 somethin 500 600
something million now so whatever he's
Worth's a billion dollars now but you
went over there but remember he went
from free to a paid subscription service
so yeah you lost I'm sure I'll get
amount of people and people call him a
sellout something like that
but just change the gay men now he is
here he is here he say oh yeah he's that
that there would be no serious about her
what serious other pants oh my how
successful is serious otherwise I mean
didn't you new Google how many how many
listeners does Howard Stern have because
remember it's because I have serious
it's I think $9.99 a month for the total
if you want the premier package with
stern Luke Thomas is on there yeah jason
Ellis was on there Andy Cohen's on there
so satellite across 30 million
subscribers this is 2016 and said how
Howard Stern added four and sixty five
thousand new net subscribers in the
first quarter twenty thirty one yes
thirty two million subscribers worldwide
old worldwide no I think serious is only
here what Rogen has worldwide now
there's no way to really know right
there's no way to know I wonder who as
far as I kiss far as pure listeners I
wonder who has more that I bet it's
close I mean bro games by far the
biggest of the podcast space and I mean
I mean destroys everyone yeah there's no
not even close but as far as bigger than
Maron and all those guys that Meryl was
number one for a while now might then
excuse me Erin compared to Rogen yeah oh
not even really are you going off iTunes
like the charts yeah no let me there I'm
in the same league huh hmm they'd had
the big one of the Obama and merin's
don't get wrong has a big podcast he's a
cult-like following for sure when it
comes to overall math they're not in the
same boat hmm they're having the same
game I don't know who is maybe compare
oh yeah I don't know man talk about the
biggest show in the world I don't know
as far as cuz Howard they don't do video
it's all audio right I think you can't
watch the video so when a video element
but I'm not sure how you watching
I don't even scribe to his I don't even
he's not on podcasts he's still a little
bit of Bolivia's to podcast cuz he'll
make fun of like I'd like a few months
ago he's like like Joe Rogan oh he has a
big podcast right and you know he is
like all the guys who work from chime in
again Howard's IQ how do you make money
like does he make any money doing that
and then the list was like well report
came out he's making like 30 million a
year and how it's like white awful
podcast and then he kind of hates us
podcast yeah but it's like you think
you'd educate someone educate him a
little bit yeah Howard's a real goddamn
pioneer man I'm a huge Howard Stern fan
yeah I'm just curious how many how many
listeners does each show get he's a guy
I guess whose dad was never was really
mean to his serious issues but he he
goes a therapy but he talks about it too
like yeah like he suit like you know
he's always demeaning and like when
someone talks um he's like I'm a [ __ ]
idiot man I'm not worth [ __ ] yeah I just
yeah he said I don't like myself I don't
like when people talk like that I don't
like that I know a lot comedies have
become except that a lot of it's a
preemptive strike yeah that's a
premature let's just guys whatever you
say about me you can't get to me because
I'm already say about my I know it's
like it's like dude let's just I don't
like that's that I hate when people do
that yeah a parachute we got [ __ ]
stupid worthless like Jesus hey yeah
yeah I'm always amazed at how many
people I talk to just happening insecure
ev'ry I bet you the rock that's fine
woke up this morning god I look fat I
would bet my last it all right I don't
know any guy including my Frank Klopas
the best body I've ever seen and a huge
hug who doesn't wake up and go God get
fat man well look man I mean self-doubt
is part of the human condition
hey chin typing uh how many listeners
does Howard Stern have maybe per show
I'm I'm just curious now do you ever
listen him journalist him back in the
day when he's on every day oh my god man
I fighters means higher than listen to
him he's a lot nicer no no this is from
May 2012 and what did it says not
subscribers how many lives does 2012
month cuz you know ass here's the other
thing serious doesn't give out numbers
the reason I stopped listening I never
listened our Stern who's this guy this
could be 10 to 20 months exactly
either could be 10 to 20 million I would
assume he's around the 10 to 20 mm yeah
100% he's getting around yeah that makes
sense
but that's 2012 is it mostly American or
is it also British in Australia I feel
like it's mostly American you know where
Rogan is worldwide yeah but still Howard
20 millions 20 million yeah Rogen's I
can't win me a list national Oh Howard
Stern is claiming that 4 million people
send daily rolling right there okay so
depend on the guest let's say his video
gets 2 to 3 million if you're a good
guess he nothing doesn't or a million
really anymore so 2 million then audio
total Rogen's right there they're
comparable and they depend on the gas
yeah I'll tell you this man though
Howard Stern when he has a celebrity in
the best interview I know I've heard
that there is nobody better I heard God
he's good at it yeah I've heard he said
most amazing interview so but the thing
is like he'll get in like you like Steve
Carell John like huge stars who do you
they know they're gone Howard and like
I'm not talking about this I'm not gonna
talk about my sex life I'm not gonna
talk about this incident and Howard will
someway get into there and then you're
like oh my god dude and then they're
just going down this [ __ ] rabbit all
of sax and who they hooked up with and
just like like he's a therapy session
yeah oh my god like when I'm when I'm
driving I do not sometimes I don't want
to get out the car the interview so good
i sat on my car that I got other day
till it was over what was 30 minutes of
who it was with I was the old one with
Pauly Shore how do you do what do you do
just go well how would you do that well
for you with the Tesla it's easy just
order you should call serious and
activate the subscription you just got
you the premium pack it's like $9.99 a
month or something like that you get all
the channels so you get great music but
then you this sounds like I'm doing a
[ __ ] read first yeah you get great
music along with Howard Stern Howard
Stern then you also get fight talk with
Luke Thomas it shows great on there yeah
cool yeah and there's political [ __ ] on
there hmm I'll check it out you like
that classical music
I'm just saying they have the whole time
to class are you starting to sound like
at me I'm old or something four million
people lists in the rep Oh - the wrap-up
show I'm doing that show that's him
saying that - that wrap-up show the MP
would call it [ __ ] yeah I know that
in Formula that's what's weird to me
well I get it's kind of like a post-show
but so how it started do his show and
then all these guys we've done that show
together right and then PJ and then
people do it after yeah like his they
recap that episode you got to be a
balls-deep fan there's no way they're
getting four million listeners that's
you another fun I'm doing sin to talk
about complicated names you guys should
get on Howard Stern that's a tough one
to get on tough one tough one god I'd
love for Howard and Rogan to get
together Rogan likes him yeah they'd
broken his little girl back in the day
no but I'm saying now yeah that would be
such a dope interview it's true thirty
point six million subscribers to the
entire Sirius XM Robin Quivers all right
let's go on to the next next one oh cool
yeah how much does Robin make though
forty five million ten million a year
damn
but have you how much bring up how much
Howard makes though so she makes ten
million I want how much he pays like
those other like the ten nine a minion
five ninety taxes in the bank interest
on that if you're even remotely
conservatives three hundred grand a year
uh three hundred million a year no says
he's worth ninety millions he earned it
an estimated 90 million that's just for
them but keeps going down 12 months
crime period so it says you had 90
million per year but he signed overall
deal keep scrolling down so he how it
sure would be the third highest paid CEO
in America click on that there did a new
five-year deal and this one in the back
I'm sure to have the numbers in there
there you go hold on
oh that's just again a year he's signed
to overall deal though so he
90 million per year guy at Discovery Oh
on a 56 million go back from each in
what was doing below that that's one
five-year deal yeah that it is here's a
thing that they're paying that cuz think
about how many people like me I bought
[ __ ] serious just for Howard exactly
did say how much the overall deal was
worth it just keeps saying eighty
million more time five would be 315
million and says the deal also includes
12 year agreement with his audio and
video archives yeah didn't do you have
to pay for the video you have to join
that package thing the subscription
package all-access since his deal was up
so they thought he would maybe go
somewhere else and then there's no sit
if Howard left stairs would burn this
area they might as well call it the
Howard yeah Network all right what you
got Jim alright
so 50 cent recently sold his I believe
it's 25 bedroom mansion in Connecticut
for three million dollars and he donated
it all to charity
he's got some money to burn well done
over that mansion from like he was on
MTV did he buy it from somebody my tyson
that's right
we're standing in Farmington Connecticut
at Curtis Jackson's home
better known as 57 who's this do we
fallen 50 claim costs 60 67 North
thousand dollars a month to maintain
just a few minutes outside of Hartford
Connecticut imagine 25 freakin bedrooms
46 Poplar Drive and when he purchased a
home he actually officially went to the
town of Farmington and add the address
legally changed to 50 poplar Drive
the house is about 54 thousand square
feet Jesus it was originally built for a
real estate developer previously owned
by Mike Tyson is quite unique screen are
over $24 yeah you'd have to have some
lovely one bedroom has a full operating
movie theater it has a billiard room
actually two billiard rooms and a poker
room where you could have pool
tournaments and know you do whatever you
want in there the upgrade a lot of the
mechanics become hotels but he also
added an exterior you would not want to
live in that now with the waterfall
absolutely if you're a young guy a ton
of friends like your friends still too
big to do it 25 rooms doesn't look good
I don't like it fake [ __ ] studio just
it just looks like a hotel can you buy
the Neverland Ranch I Britian Neverland
Ranch 9 million I think pretty sure it's
nine million well you want it yeah it's
in Santa Barbara okay candy Spelling's
house that was the biggest house in
Southern California whose candy spello
tori spelling's table I went there wait
is that whoa I'm Way off a hundred
million dollars in 2015 you know what
it's a deal now six said lower price I
said nine I lied
maybe's house off of like she's raised
it a lot dude and I was hoping for not
right dude your instant ident Wow Wow
Santa Barbara the night given we land
out there no they're not this house in
Encino though was I think six million
for sale I I just couldn't do it I just
can't even if it was two million for
that place I couldn't do it you should
get the land let's change it bulldoze it
over just for the land just change do
you see his uh you did all energy lose
your body um did it seem yeah you look
tired
today I just got done no we were talking
about Howard Stern and I was like I got
bored come on fair did you uh his his
maid came out and said she died just
from I think she's from Ireland she came
out and said that she used to clean up
after Michael Jackson and the horrible
details horrible what she was the I mean
for people not thinking the pedophiles
insane
she was I used to have to clean up after
you have parties with these boys why
would his makes me sick they're saying
in the hot tub and his underwear being
their kids under would be in there she
said she have to clean behind like
drawers and they'd be like crusty undies
that were yellow like sticky and so so
so if she sang it
what was she personal maid exposed yeah
go to the video this one of the one in
buck go to the back go back go to that
one right there the first one yeah there
you go video personal made what and what
does she have to gain from this nothing
absolutely no she's aged well with a
Daily Mail exclusive that will have
everybody talking Michael Jackson's
secret closet the King of Pop's personal
maid is making some astonishing new
claims about what she discovered while
cleaning Jackson's bedroom for four
years this may just make you feel sick
up Jackson's Neverland Ranch in now
she's revealing only to us that Jackson
may have had a secret stash of sex tapes
this shocking admission is just one of
the new details emerging about Michael
Jackson and now McManus is divulging she
saw and what she tried to do about it I
think anybody that came in contact with
him has been destroyed and they suffered
because it was something not right with
him he's a pedophile she began working
for Michael Jackson in 1993 the same
year stunning allegations of child
molestation first surfaced the most
loving thing to do is to share your bit
with someone this was her work ID comb
gave her access to the popstar secret
chambers where she allegedly witnessed
his disturbing behavior with young
children with all the little boys he
would hold their hands and kiss them
Adrian McManus says Michael would often
take baths with his so-called special
guests in the jacuzzi in his bedroom
Michael would have his underwears
floating in the water and the little
boys underwear loading in the water
together if they weren't floating in the
water they were outside of the on the
floor around the jacuzzi McManus was
also shocked by what she says she
covered while cleaning Jackson's home
there was a lot of Vaseline it's brown
Schieffelin a lot in Michaels bedroom I
found underwears
that were in back of in Michael's main
room in one of the closets they were
very hard and crunchy and yellow
I ain't didn't know who they belong to
she says Jackson was obsessed with
capturing everything on camera and had a
walk-in closet filled with expensive
camera equipment one day she stumbled
upon a secret collection of VHS tapes I
think they were of Michael with boys
doing inappropriate things I think there
were probably sex tapes didn't want to
watch them warned to never reveal what
she saw I was told by Michaels
bodyguards that they could hire a hitman
to take me out that they could have
somebody slice my neck and you'd never
find my body you just do what you're
told to do you don't question him she
went on to testify against Jackson
during his 2005 election trial there you
go
now nearly three decades after working
for Jackson she says the memories of
what she witnessed still haunt her I
wish that more people would have spoke
up because maybe today and Michael would
still be alive if they would have put
him in prison
Adrian McManus exclaims come in the wake
of the documentary leaving Neverland
detailing the long-term alleged abuse
two men suffered at the hands of Jackson
when they were children
yep what a [ __ ] month there you go
it's hard not to with all that evidence
you know you you [ __ ] slept with boys
and took baths with him the [ __ ] out of
here
eight-year-olds nothing with his mate
that I don't know what did she write if
she had a book coming out if she had a
podcast coming out of some [ __ ] then I'm
like I what is she what her motives but
this lady just seems like she she
testified against them and she's just in
2005 there's nothing to gain here he's
just a fine she's a crazy person so [ __ ]
he's crazy
he's sick man yeah SEC sick it makes a
beat crazy
a lot of people seem to have protected
him King of Pop yeah that's not good
what else we got we got this well you
guys fans of the Cure at all I love him
the cure we give me a song log here I
will always love you oh yeah I want to
slit my wrists but not curious
I hope Robert Smith is the guy that
heads it so unique incredible and this
girl I guess she was on the red carpet
when they're induct him into the Hall of
Fame the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
then she was like super excited and the
way he reacted became viral he doesn't
give a [ __ ] vampire Wow sounds of it no
no he was nice during the actual
interview though he's she was crunk then
Jeff is super drunk he he said she in a
voice there was a such a unique band
still are I mean no they still Toria I'm
sure I don't know they were my favorite
did for a while they were like one of my
favorite bands your cave one of them
were you Motley Crue Finn no Def Leppard
no I mean they're great but now they
were dull now they're they're a great
rock and roll like heavy metal you like
rock and roll I did but they they were
always a little too on the nose for me
the Cure was just such a unique
different sound
ACC ah yes Led Zeppelin number one for
me Led Zeppelin number one number one
doing everything and everything there is
no man like them never has but I've
talked to big-time musicians who are
like oh that's high math oh that old
Zeppelin that everything stops the
instra you know Smith yeah amazing
Jackson five of course Michael Jackson
definitely you're a fan
yeah I knew about the boys yeah now I'll
listen to him differently here where I
won't I don't know I I just died I can't
I change his music now God he had some
yeah but it's like he was a look he was
a brilliant brilliant artist who
happened to be a pedophile it seems but
it doesn't it still he's still a
brilliant there's Sue's age there's
still some brilliant people that did
some great things to move society
forward that are terrible people sure
especially look back how far you Martin
Luther King they say beat the [ __ ] out
of his wife so what do you all like
richest all right Richard Mayer missus
and Tara legacy or an overage probably
top three comics of all time yeah some
real problems yeah domestic violence all
that sir
so like again again it goes back to what
I'm just washed my whole display will
theme of my [ __ ] specialist is I get
older is like we're not verbs I mean
we're not nouns you may have a bad side
to you but we're complicated people
pedophile though you're out though you
know yes unfortunately it's not
something I can really work with you're
out I can't work with it now you know
don't need you mean go down a list I'm
like okay don't need you me antlers
cancer all that stuff yeah I mean
there's certain things where we like
they can't have you I don't need your
contribution people I they kill people
just randomly kill out of it yeah but if
it's just strangers I kill strains all
your murder we gotta go yeah this
certain things man what else she got
this teacher who was fired because she
sent a selfie of her boobs to her
boyfriend at the time this is three
years ago who was at another school
district and somehow a kid was able to
get that picture that's the mystery well
soccer yeah I don't know how that would
even happen there was a student but she
said in the picture to her teacher
fatah years ago who gives a [ __ ] so she
was fired so now she's suing the school
district is you want to see her yeah I
do do they get the [ __ ] blur out in
January a student somehow got his hands
on that three years on now sure and
after being on a home assignment for
three months
Miranda was told last week she was fired
that's her that's her how it got out is
the million dollar question the three
million so hot she's pretty hot rate has
filed a notice of claim asking for
Miranda to be reinstated or the school
district will have to pay up she says
she is being discriminative act and work
there though I agree were displayed
there would be no punishment
she says she first spoke to the
principal I support her I definitely
support her well that's your point
district officials been help so what do
you think of that like the principal is
like now that your goes wrong what we
what the principal's say I can't do in
front of a classroom now when all the
boys have seen that picture and they're
gonna look Oh No
ly : Oh No every boy every boy's gonna
have a rock-hard boner while they come
into the history class now and that's
usually hate to tell you they had a
boner anyway they didn't need to act
right um she's hottest yeah she's she's
every boys fantasy I bet you then when a
fire if she was in hot if she was busted
I would still have a job cuz they'd be
like well no Larry
either way it's [ __ ] and that's
terrible and also let's find that
picture so I wouldn't net that's gambler
um how about this one they found the UH
the guy that is allegedly Nipsey Hussle
murderer
where'd they find him Bellflower gee the
guy's was from a tip sold at 3:00 in the
afternoon he walks up in front of a
bunch of witnesses and shoots three
people like this is a forward-thinking
guy [ __ ] he said though they think it
was some sort of argument that there I
was and then he came back with his back
with a gun yeah and hild and murdered
and murdered a brilliant man did he
murder more than that because no hustle
lived in the neighborhood was trying to
he gives back the
I mean in every way there's not 1% a bad
thing that would ever say a bad thing
who was it just told me last night he
said nipsey was there who the [ __ ] was
the comic and he said he was a comic and
he was there and nipsey was there who
the [ __ ] is it anyway
Nipsey bought 10 of his shirts to help
him out he just looked over on nipsey
had bought a shirt it's a [ __ ]
beautiful person and this this is a
piece of [ __ ] this guy who's obviously
doesn't think much of himself either
though you know there's a getaway driver
right yes there was a girl female right
apparently she's not gonna have any
charges against her at least at the
moment because she tipped him off or she
actually gave the you know where the
whereabouts and who knows maybe shitty
on the streets he's known as shitty you
know it's the worst nickname ever yeah
come on man or [ __ ] he's that know you
can trust shitty god knows what happened
to him god knows what his childhood was
don't care what it is yeah relating to
this man there was a vigil but the
visual became really really violent too
I'll show you a little bit of a footage
just last night or two nights ago
because last night it was way better
two nights ago this that always better
look at all this mayhem you mention
people start stabbing others they said
there were some people stabbed but then
some people think that you know when
they're running and stampeding the
bottles break and then they just get cut
up 17 people injured what I was seeing
on the news is like knows her people
rolled their hands chest I'm like de
nuit you've never had your ankles Los
Angeles that ship is let's show awful
really its shanked in the back i gen
roll my ankle in formal candlelight it's
supposed to be like for support the hip
last night was supported hustle look at
this viola you can see
so many pairs upset men that were lost
as people work honestly [ __ ] lives
people were screaming they were cry this
is an area that I was talking about
earlier that was covered in candles oh
my gosh look at that
it's a child's shoe a child lost their
shoe here they have lined the perimeter
with those officers you can see them
running right now just random fights
breaking out at the middle of these
violence very very voluntary that's
that's how you grow up sometimes humans
make me distressing yeah I see that
stuff pocket of the world where violence
a lot of my so frustrated man if he was
killed it's so hard break it's terrible
it'll ruin mass I mean no the guy is my
video really upset do some research on
look him up it was such a great person
to play my community listen he was
recently trying to like what the next
day well Chief of Police I hope them
make the community better but you got
this kind of [ __ ] in that community you
got this and enjoy that good luck good
luck and personal responsibility has to
be taken also think about it he's a he's
uh he's a [ __ ] he's your guy man he
represents and what that is good in your
community get Shang you murder and
murder him murder in three o'clock in
Bryant a mess again this is very forward
thinking yeah [ __ ] man yeah what else
good yeah you want on one Church in all
right this is a little not enough to
bring this up for now cuz it's what
can't get dark is that because it has to
do with religion but Conor McGregor
tweeted to khabib so that's could be
even his wife and then they have that
traditional assertive traditional we're
games for them right yeah and then
Connor said like your wife has a towel
or your wife is a towel or some like
there's a towel right did not have you
seen what could be posted this morning
no so now here's the problem so this is
this rivalry has gone from fun let's
watch the fight to and yeah it's tough
for me to say cross
I cross line every goddamn day on to gun
shows but now it's been crossed because
then khabib post a picture of Connor for
sure find it you can probably go to keep
peeps could be post picture of Connor
with his a side piece with his hand up
her dress in your rapist justice will be
served like it's I think he had to Billy
it yep he had to delete it unless it's
not his Institute are sorry Twitter
mom's reap on both but you can check I
would imagine that him take it down cop
I would imagine
Dana probably called both hand was like
T because there's there's not me I'm
giving to take it down there it is
rapist you are rapist you're a hypocrite
who's not response for your actions
justice will find you look at that
picture cross the line now man yeah yeah
like that's not fun for me anymore
hi Connor say he's a talent with like
his wife's with a towel it's like y'all
[ __ ] man dad gets [ __ ] up and then
I've seen his ass yeah Connor has the
rape allegations right yeah alright and
your this is the girl times new at times
picked it up oh this is the girl this is
what people were saying was the girl
I've never seen this a while ago they're
saying she's doing who's rape do you
know how it all started like caught Orca
beep tweeted something like Connors like
a ex-wife that talks Matt but then
doesn't really yeah just you talking
about the UFC never leaves but just
keeps talking smack and then Connor took
it that far with the towel comment look
man I just know who beat the [ __ ] out of
him so I don't know what he's doing I
don't know what I don't know what he's
getting out of this does you want
another fight with khabib there's no
this is tiring I agree this is like no
it's not fun anymore what is this do you
have fun anymore
this is this cocaine talking what is
this
no we're gone bro I'm not talking about
Connor
that's not cocaine talking that's what
he does you get right over the line he's
always done this crazy [ __ ] but he's I
thought he was retiring as he fired but
I mean to fight welcome to 2019 he's
he's been tweeting every day crazy [ __ ]
yeah whenever fighter wins he post
whenever a fighter loses
he just that's how he stays relevant he
stays in the news yeah well he's the
most fair of less clumsy ways to do it
yeah no [ __ ]
this this is but could be to let's not
defend kebede this isn't right either
yeah I just think that the that Connor
makes is so personal that I think you
know I don't blame him could be even in
this case oh wow yeah I don't support
either of them I think both of them are
wrong
well if I were could be right just not
say anything but yeah I don't support
either it I don't [ __ ] with either I'm
not entertained by either of it I don't
support could be but a lot more than I
support Connor a lot I don't now with
the rape charges especially let's say
it's not true UN fuel the fire in this
culture you're talking about he's
probably gonna lose million Connor
Connor is actually in my opinion because
I know a little bit about the politics
there I believe Connor from from day one
was actually putting his father and at
at risk
yeah in jeopardy was like it I don't I
don't think I think I was insulting his
religious culture his father has now his
wife and I think all of that is over the
line I think it's I think it's it made
me lose respect for Connor including
against him and he deleted it now I'm
rooting if they do fight I'm rooting for
khabib to flatten his [ __ ] face so if
I'm saying that it would guy who likes
it and I it really makes me mad so I'm
100% in khabib camp
all my money's in him in every way in
every way well I think yeah could be
definitely impede them but I don't think
I'm not talking about X's nose inside
thought I'm talking about this post this
great forum as a personal rapist pole
yeah is not too much for you be it is
it's too much I don't like it either
like you even like even I'm getting sick
of Connor stuff you guys know me I do
think I know but I don't like with the
listen when you talk about rape
allegations in this current climate and
we don't know if he did or not and then
you post this it's like a [ __ ] man I I
would if I had been there as his friend
something else I would said maybe don't
do this I don't think it's yeah I think
it's just posted it's kind of sinking I
would just post a picture of me choking
them out like alright you got there yeah
that'd be we always talk about that
humorous way better there's a better way
to do it i I agree that this is not
effective you know
these low blows are just [ __ ] they're
ugly uncomfortable yeah they're ugly
they're not sport anymore they're not
trash talk they're something else I
think we all recognize it yeah a lighter
note just to get the last one in yeah
what do you takes on this so this this
is an actor from power and that 50 cent
produces that show and he was saying hi
to Beyonce and gave her a kiss on the
lips no no no on the side well I'll let
you watch it and then you judge it see
if it's that because a lot of people are
not like jay-z looks crazy right there I
know that last one well that's because
it was close to the mouth why tell them
all the [ __ ] off so the sounds you're a
pig
tell me go [ __ ] themselves so all of
Europe is wrong you politically correct
[ __ ] here hold on one deal Hughley
posted well yeah he's a comic know a lot
of people posted little spotty cheapo
really all of you dumb virtue signalers
all you dumb virtue signalers yeah I'm
seeing a backlash that that is the most
I'd like kissed on the lip that's the
most hilarious should I've ever seen in
my life
that's European because it got close
didn't you do it twice yeah a little bit
and he's not European so I hear you I'm
just saying is I know I hear in France
I'm sure it's also ridiculous the
sadness I'll say this the second if
Beyonc is my girl that I would have to
be like dude Jesus Christ to would have
made fun of one yeah add yeah we're not
in Europe so I hear be but the sermon
that we incent okay that's what he was
doing the guy was literally like hey how
are you look at this look at this giant
[ __ ]
skrelp right there he goes respectful
handshake would have worked just fine
for omaree women don't need to be
grabbed hug kiss unless it's your wife
hashtag girlfriend [ __ ] fiance should
have slapped him oh my god let me go
back to my basement and jack off the
wall and [ __ ] loser this is [ __ ]
man this is all [ __ ] this is all
news that doesn't exist this is the
extremists yeah
okay all right today calls hip with it
though
I don't I don't I don't kiss people on
the cheeks I do I do I do now this is
the most ridiculous this is the kind of
[ __ ] do for a hug would you kiss that I
don't know you make a mistake you're
going for the kiss name yeah he's not
trying to make out xenon say he's all of
these people tweeting are complete
idiots oh my God look at this [ __ ]
real quick Amar'e Hardwick psycho kiss
was unnecessary uncomfortable don't do
that again angry so now you're not we
women so often get touched
kiss groped and poked and this is
exactly like this we don't like it all
caps not angry it's time to no longer
let these moments of discomfort slide
don't apologize hit on apologize no mark
do not apologize now talk to it's all
[ __ ] well why don't we talk to Beyonce
I bet you go of knives zero problem with
it it's just the ugly church be like I
don't like to be hugged kiss or touch
you know why cuz ain't nobody hugging
tussin and kiss thank you
[ __ ] hot ones like yeah I don't have a
purse madness this politically correct
madness is getting the way of human
contact interaction now if you own the
thing kiss one other yeah I'll do that
to you right now you won't stay [ __ ]
about it you I'm talking about you stop
resting your nose like it bothers nah
man you're boring me today bro with your
head you're boring me [ __ ] make out
we got anything else chin that's it [ __ ]
yes yeah come see me this puppy in
Calgary this weekend sorry I think
tickets are gone but there might be
shows left for the final of the
late-night show Friday the Thursday New
Mexico New Mexico at the stage star ana
ana ana star casino santa ana star
casino people not want to 12 13 you make
denver make shut up not whatever april
25 26 27 kate you takes Comedy Works
downtown
Brandon I'll do your things Brandon I'll
be in Pasadena Friday Rogan Derek post
in a sauna mod did Friday two shows
they're almost sold out it gets out to
you know Friday I don't know
Friday Pasadena ice house two shows one
at 8 o'clock
at ten o'clock the Ice House in Pasadena
then Phoenix Phoenix end of the month
stand-up live in Phoenix
Friday and Saturday the 26th 27th and
then just announced Tampa Tampa improv
May 10th through the 11th two shows
Friday to Saturday that is Tampa Bay
Florida baby throwback Steve Young
Jersey baby baby pack a calm for tickets
San Antonio I'm rescheduling that's that
week is the same week my special drops
have to be in New York to do press for
it so I had to reschedule don't worry
don't be sad I'm coming back there I'll
have an announcement for you for San
Antonio
all right Pasadena see you Friday
Phoenix see the 26 Tampa see in May
t back a.com for tickets Brian you know
if I got up this is the bottom kid we're
out